hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the National Grid decide not to trigger
a blackout plan which would have seen
households paid for restricting their
electricity usage
do your bits how the government is
promising to reduce your energy bills
without having to make huge sacrifices
new onshore wind projects could be given
the green light with talks of a u-turn
on the ban following pressure from MPS
and cleaner Rhodes the latest on plans
for London's ultra low emission Zone to
be expanded to the whole city but is it
fair on drivers
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis
the National Grid has decided not to
enact an emergency blackout plan today
that would have seen households across
the country being paid for limiting the
amount of electricity they use
forecasters projected a large drop in
the amount of power that would regularly
be available from France although
emergency procedures aren't going ahead
suppliers are still warning that the
power supply will be tight in both
Britain and France Tonight meaning both
countries will need to import power from
abroad let's take a look at how the
system would have worked well the demand
flexibility Service as it's known as a
voluntary scheme where households can
save money by Saving energy
volunteers are alerted when Energy
savings need to be made and if they cut
their usage they'll receive money back
now octopus which is the biggest energy
provider taking part says its customers
say between one pound and four pounds in
a recent hour-long trial and up to 100
megawatts of electricity was saved in
those trials that's the equivalent of
the output output of a small power plant
well our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter is
here now to give us more context Hannah
what would this have meant for us and
indeed what does this mean for us well
the National Grid's responsibility is to
balance the system to make sure that
Supply equals demand and it looked ahead
to tomorrow night where there's that big
football match of course between England
and Wales about seven o'clock it's
actually also not very warm and it has
been quite still so we can't really rely
on wind power like we might normally do
at this time of year the other issue is
that the French nuclear power stations
are really reducing their capacity at
the moment because they're undergoing a
lot of Maintenance and so the National
Grid has to turn elsewhere one of the
things it might do to plug the Gap is to
fire up coal power plants but also it
was considering activating this brand
new scheme to ask British consumers
those with Smart Meters who signed up
for it to reduce their consumption
during peak hours to alleviate pressure
on the grid now the real issue here came
because the grid has said it's going to
give consumers and their supplies around
24 hours notice each time this might be
necessary so it is potentially something
we could see more of for the rest of the
winter and it shows just how unstable
things are in terms of our energy it
does and you know electricity is dealt
with on an hour-by-hour day-by-day basis
the forecasting is very difficult very
technical and that the National Grid
would say look the demand flexibility to
service is something that we announced
at the beginning beginning of October we
said that the scheme should run between
nov November and March next year it
precisely to deal with this situation
where there isn't enough electricity
coming from Europe but still we all set
up and paid attention didn't we when the
National Grid said actually some
consumers are going to have to reduce
their consumption in order potentially
to avoid blackouts we certainly did
Hannah thank you
meanwhile the government announced a new
one billion pound Eco plus scheme aiming
to support those in the least energy
efficient homes now the goal is for the
UK to become energy independent and
although there will be financial support
what kind of action is the government
urging people to take it home well let's
take a look reducing boiler flow
temperature from 75 degrees Celsius to
60 degrees Celsius is one example
turning down radiators in empty rooms is
another and draft proofing windows and
doors so heat can't escape homes is
recommended too well Skies Chief
political correspondent John Craig joins
me now with more on this uh hello to you
John what more can you tell us about
this new scheme
well it's a two-pronged attack really on
energy bills being launched by Grant
shaft the business secretary now first
of all there is that Eco plus scheme
that essentially is about home
insulation and the government claims
that with the help that they're
providing that'll save consumers around
uh 310 pounds a year the second part is
that advice you just been talking about
um turning down the boilers uh turning
off radiators in empty rooms and also
draft excluded stuff like that uh Mr
shouts was speaking on Sky News Today he
claimed to be leading by example he said
he's turned down the boiler flow
temperature at his home he says it's not
just your thermostats this is the boiler
itself it could potentially save you a
lot of money so that is the plan uh that
Mr shaps is announcing today the
publicity scheme was vetoed when it was
suggested the towed by Liz truss and the
then business secretary uh William Jacob
Reese mogg Nanny State they claimed well
it's going ahead now
and John there's been talk today of a
potential U-turn by the government when
it comes to onshore win tell us more
about that
well it's that man Mr Sharps again yes
what is happening is that there is a
bill going through Parliament uh Michael
Gove the leveling up secretary's got a
leveling up and regeneration bill now
there's already been a clash with Rebel
MPS over house building targets now
there's a clash with backbenches over
onshore wind though this is an amendment
put down by the former leveling up
secretary under Liz trust Simon Clark
and look at some of the names on it they
want to reverse the ban Liz truss and
Boris Johnson amongst the signatures so
what Mr shaps has said on Sky News Today
signaling a U-turn is that where
communities are in favor of it well
sounds as though they can go ahead
where onshore wind happens it needs to
happen with local consent uh what is
being proposed uh is something which
would guarantee that local incentives to
say I haven't studied all the
ramifications uh of that in terms of the
planning changes we need and I'll be
talking about this more later in the
week I've just talked spoken to you
about measures to reduce energy use we
also need to make sure that we reduce
more energy and we'll be doing that
well Rishi sunak made his views clear on
this during the summer Leadership
campaign uh when he put out a press
release saying plans to relax onshore
Wind Farm ban in England to be scrapped
uh he said he'd promise plans to to
scrap plants to relax the ban providing
certainty to rural communities he said I
want to reassure communities I would
scrap plans to relax the ban well sounds
as though there is a u-turn on the way
in the face of uh pressure from some of
those big beasts on the Tory back
benches including two the two most
recent former Prime Ministers okay John
we appreciate your update thank you
time for a look at some of today's other
climate stories now and the prince and
princess of Wales were set to fly to
Boston in the U.S later this week for
this year's Earth shot prize awards
ceremony Billy eilish will headline the
environmental Awards with 15 finalists
vying for a million pounds awarded to
each of the five category winners the
shortlist for the competition which is
in its second year includes london-based
notpler hard material that makes
packaging from seaweed and plants
now how big of a priority is tackling
climate change for you well a study has
found that concerns about the climate
crisis was the number one reason that
prompted people in Australia to vote for
an independent candidate during the
country's Federal elections Australia is
heavily reliant on coal but attempted to
give fresh hopes at cop 27 this year in
a bid to rebuild its environmental
reputation
the survey looking at Native muscles
which live on the bed of the River
Thames has found that their population
has declined by 95 since the 1960s
scientists carried out the study in a
stretch of the Thames near Reading and
discovered one native species had
vanished completely mussels were a great
indicator of the health of a River's
ecosystem and researchers say the sharp
decline could be due to changes in land
land use along the river or changes in
the fish population
now the mayor of London has announced
that London's ultra low emission zone or
ulez will be expanded from August next
year the changes will mean that drivers
of older cars who enter the greater
London Authority boundary will face a
daily fee of 12 pounds 50 for using the
city's roads but is it an effective way
of switching drivers over to clean it
Vehicles well joining me now is Neil
Gregg director of policy and research at
I am roadsmart and Quentin Wilson
motoring journalist
and founder of the campaign Fair change
a very warm welcome to you thank you for
joining us uh Neil to you first if I may
uh what do you make of this new scheme
well I think it can't be a surprise to
drivers that this is coming and this is
happening in several other cities across
the UK in Scotland in Bristol for
example they've launched a similar
scheme with the same kind of Standards
so I think we knew it was coming I think
what we didn't expect was such a large
area of London to be covered once you
start moving away from the central areas
for the very good public transport
Alternatives it starts to make less
sense because you're not giving a clear
message to people as to what you want
them to do people will still need to
have cars to move around the whole of
London that's absolutely certain the mix
of Journeys cannot be replicated by
public transport so we are very
concerned that this bigger area will
actually lead to more people having to
continue to use their cars and that's
for the cost of 12 pounds 50 every
single day 365 days a year uh Quentin
your view on an extension of this scheme
uh Neil's saying there that it could
lead to more people using cars what
would you say to that
we have to do something about the air
quality in London because we all know
it's dire and and the strong message is
being sent out are important the timing
of this is regrettable in the middle of
a cost of living crisis but we need
somehow to get these old polluting
diesels off the road and it's the
pollution you can see it's called ultra
fine particles pm10s PM 2.5S and there's
a have a stack of research that says
there's a connection a direct connection
between Cancer and Alzheimer's and and a
raft of other diseases so it's it's it's
not a great time to be doing this but we
have to do it because we know that 50 of
all pollution in in urban areas comes
from transport and the bulk of that from
old badly maintained diesel vehicles
now what do you say to that you know
it's not a great time to be doing this
with the cost of living crisis but we
have to do it would you agree that by
August next year this will be a viable
option for drivers
well for some drivers it will be that's
the problem for many people particularly
with the older petrol Vehicles they'll
be very old you have a very old petrol
vehicle to fall follow these new
regulations but you could have had a a a
new wrist of a new diesel bot since 2015
and of course you may have well
maintained that you may have looked
after it and of course you may have
maybe your company vehicle your van for
example and that's the problem with
these sort of big measures they're very
blunt instruments they don't take into
account people's incomes people's need
for the car people's Alternatives and
also we're getting some mixed messages
at the moment as well because we're
starting to see uh vehicle excise duty
going on to electric vehicles for
example now if the government really
wants people to get into electric cars
they should be looking to make sure that
they make those incentives for electric
cars even better as well as having these
controls on our old or polluting
vehicles at the same time
uh and Quentin
um do you think there are enough
incentives and support in place for
people to move to Greener vehicles
no and I think the government is
thinking well look it will organically
the market will organically get better
and better it still needs support
because the price of these electric cars
are high and the price of electricity is
high I've been campaigning for getting
the government to reduce the vat on
public charging from 20 to 5 but we also
need things like free parking across
London for electric cars maybe the use
of of priority Lanes or bus lanes for
for low polluting and electric vehicles
so there's a lot of things that both the
government and and transport for London
could do to make it more palatable and
you know the battle for for clean air
isn't over yet and electrification it's
being challenged at the moment by rasp
of economic factors so again less stick
and more carrot
and they'll just briefly before I let
you both go
um the ultra low emission Zone was first
introduced in 2019. what difference has
it made
well it's certainly have gotten a lot of
income to tfl and I think that's one of
the issues here as well if they could
show more clearly the benefits of where
this income is going fewer potholes more
cycle Lanes cheaper public transport
make that direct link between money
they're taking from all their polluting
vehicles and new ideas to make a
transport cleaner and to make it easier
and cheaper then people might be more
supportive but as I say the bigger the
area gets the more that link is broken
and the more it's more difficult for
people to actually give up their
vehicles okay Neil Greg Quentin Wilson
it's been a pleasure speaking to you
both thank you for joining us today on
the climate show
foreign
now and a reminder you can watch Tom
heaps climate show on Saturdays and
Sundays that's at 3 30 in the afternoon
or at 7 30 in the evening but for now
that is all from us for today we'll see
you again at the same time tomorrow
thanks very much for watching see you
then